The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Continuing
in the theme
of sorting in general, but
in particular, binary search
trees, which are a
kind of way of doing
dynamic sorting,
if you will, where
the elements are
coming and going.
And at all times, you want
to know the sorted order
of your elements by storing them
in a nice binary search tree.
Remember, in general, a
binary search tree is a tree.
It's binary, and it has
the search property.
Those three things.
This is a rooted binary tree.
It has a root.
It's binary, so there's a
left child and a right child.
Some nodes lack a
right or left child.
Some nodes lack both.
Every node has a key.
This is the search part.
You store key in every node,
and you have this BST property,
or also called the
search property,
that every node-- if you
have a node the stores key x,
everybody in the left subtree
stores a key that's less than
or equal to x, and everyone
that's in the right subtree
stores a key that's
greater than or equal to x.
So not just the left
and right children,
but every descendant way
down there is smaller than x.
Every descendent way down
there is greater than x.
So when you have a binary
search tree like this,
if you want to know
the sorted order,
you do what's called
an in-order traversal.
You look at a node.
You recursively
visit the left child.
Then you print out the root.
Then you recursively
visit the right child.
So in this case, we'd
go left, left, print 11.
Print 20.
Go right.
Go left.
Print 26.
Print 29.
Go up.
Print 41.
Go right.
Print 50.
Print 65.
Then check that's
in sorted order.
If you're not familiar
with in-order traversal,
look at the textbook.
It's a very simple operation.
I'm not going to talk
about it more here,
except we're going to use it.
All right, we'll get to the
topic of today's lecture
in a moment, which is balance.
What we saw in last
lecture and recitation
is that these
basic binary search
trees, where when you insert
a node you just walk down
the tree to find where that item
fits-- like if you're trying
to insert 30, you go left here,
go right here, go right here,
and say, oh 30 fits here.
Let's put 30 there.
If you keep doing that,
you can do insert.
You can do delete.
You can do these
kinds of searches,
which we saw, finding
the next larger element
or finding the next
smaller element, also known
as successor and predecessor.
These are actually the typical
names for those operations.
You can solve them
in order h time.
Anyone remember what h was?
The height.
Yeah, good.
The height of the tree.
So h is the height of the BST.
What is the height of the tree?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Log n?
Log n would be great,
but not always.
So this is the issue
of being balance.
So in an ideal
world, your tree's
going to look
something like this.
I've drawn this picture probably
the most in my academic career.
This is a nice, perfectly
balanced binary search tree.
The height is log n.
This would be the balance case.
I mean, roughly log n.
Let's just put theta
to be approximate.
But as we saw at the
end of last class,
you can have a very unbalanced
tree, which is just a path.
And there the height is n.
What's the definition of height?
That's actually what
I was looking for.
Should be 6.042 material.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it the
length of the longest path
always going down?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, length of the
longest path always going down.
So length of the longest path
from the root to some leaf.
That's right.
OK, so this is--
I highlight this
because we're going
to be working a lot
with height today.
All that's happening here, all
of the paths are length log n.
Here, there is a
path of length n.
Some of them are shorter,
but in fact, the average path
is n over 2.
It's really bad.
So this is very unbalanced.
I'll put "very."
It's not a very formal
term, but that's
like the worst case for BSTs.
This is good.
This does have a
formal definition.
We call a tree balanced if
the height is order log n.
So you're storing n keys.
If your height is
always order log n,
we get a constant factor here.
Here, it's basically exactly
log n, 1 times log n.
It's always going to
be at least log n,
because if you're storing
n things in a binary tree,
you need to have
height at least log n.
So in fact, it will be theta
log n if your tree is balanced.
And today's goal is
to always maintain
that your trees are balanced.
And we're going to do
that using the structure
called AVL trees, which
I'll define in a moment.
They're the original
way people found
to keep trees balanced
back in the '60s,
but they're still
kind of the simplest.
There are lots of ways
to keep a tree balanced,
so I'll mention some other
balance trees later on.
In particular, your textbook
covers two other ways to do it.
It does not cover AVL
trees, so pay attention.
One more thing I
wanted to define.
We talked about the
height of the tree,
but I'd also like to talk about
the height of a node in a tree.
Can anyone define this for me?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's the level
that the node is at.
PROFESSOR: The level
That is roughly right.
I mean, that is right.
It's all about, what
is the level of a node?
AUDIENCE: Like how many
levels of children it has.
PROFESSOR: How many
That's basically right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: The distance
from it to the root.
PROFESSOR: Distance
That would be the depth.
So depth is counting from above.
Height is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, longest path
from that node to the leaf.
Note that's why I wrote
this definition actually,
to give you a hint.
Here I should probably
say down to be precise.
You're not allowed to
go up in these paths.
[INAUDIBLE]
All right.
Sorry.
I've got to learn how to throw.
All right.
So for example, over here I'm
going to write depths in red.
If you're taking notes it's OK.
Don't worry.
So length off the longest
path from it down to a leaf.
Well, this is a leaf,
so its height is 0.
OK.
Yeah, I'll just
leave it at that.
It takes 0 steps to get
from a leaf to a leaf.
This guy's not a leaf.
It has a child, but it has a
path of length one to a leaf.
So it's one.
This guy has a choice.
You could go left and you
get a path of length 1,
or you could go right and
get a path of length 2.
We take the max, so
this guy has height 2.
This node has height 1.
This node has height 3.
How do you compute
the height of a node?
Anyone?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Max of the height
of the children plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Right.
You take the max of the
height of the children.
Here, 2 and 1.
Max is 2.
Add 1.
You get 3.
So it's going to always
be-- this is just a formula.
The height of the
left child maxed
with the height of the
right child plus 1.
This is obviously
useful for computing.
And in particular, in
lecture and recitation
last time, we saw
how to maintain
the size of every tree using
data structure augmentation.
Data structure augmentation.
And then we started with a
regular vanilla binary search
tree, and then we
maintained-- every time
we did an operation
on the tree, we also
updated the size of
the subtree rooted
at that node, the size field.
Here, I want to
store a height field,
and because I have this nice
local rule that tells me
how to compute the height
of a node using just
local information-- the height
of its left child, the height
of its right child.
Do a constant
amount of work here.
There's a general theorem.
Whenever you have a
nice local formula
like this for updating
your information in terms
of your children,
then you can maintain
it using constant overhead.
So we can store the height
of every node for free.
Why do I care?
Because AVL trees are going to
use the heights of the nodes.
Our goal is to keep
the heights small.
We don't want this.
We want this.
So a natural thing to
do is store the heights.
When they get too big, fix it.
So that's what
we're going to do.
Maybe one more thing to mention
over here for convenience.
Leaves, for example, have
children that are-- I mean,
they have null pointers to
their left and right children.
You could draw them
explicitly like this.
Also some nodes just
lack a single child.
I'm going to define the
depths of these things
to be negative 1.
This will be
convenient later on.
Why negative 1?
Because then this formula works.
You can just think about it.
Like leaves, for example,
have two children,
which are negative 1.
You take the max.
You add 1.
You get 0.
So that just makes
things work out.
We don't normally draw
these in the pictures,
but it's convenient that I don't
have to do special cases when
the left child doesn't exist and
the right child doesn't exist.
You could either
do special cases
or you could make
this definition.
Up to you.
OK.
AVL trees.
So the idea with an AVL
tree is the following.
We'd like to keep the
height order log n.
It's a little harder to think
about keeping the height order
log n than it is to think
about keeping the tree balance,
meaning the left and right
sides are more or less equal.
In this case, we're
going to think about them
as being more or
less equal in height.
You could also think
about them being
more or less equal
in subtree size.
That would also work.
It's a different
balanced search tree.
Height is kind of the
easiest thing to work with.
So if we have a node,
it has a left subtree.
It has a right subtree,
which we traditionally
draw as triangles.
This subtree has a height.
We'll call it HL for left.
By the height of the subtree,
I mean the height of its root.
And the right subtree
has some height, r.
I've drawn them as the
same, but in general they
might be different.
And what we would like
is that h sub l and h
sub r are more or less the same.
They differ by at
most an additive 1.
So if I look at h sub l minus
h sub r in absolute value,
this is at most
1, for every node.
So I have some node x.
For every node x, I want
the left and right subtrees
to be almost balanced.
Now, I could say
differ by at most 0,
that the left and right have
exactly the same heights.
That's difficult,
because that really
forces you to have
exactly the perfect tree.
And in fact, it's not even
possible for odd n or even n
or something.
Because at the very
end you're going
to have one missing child, and
then you're unbalanced there.
So 0's just not
possible to maintain,
but 1 is almost as
good, hopefully.
We're going to prove
that in a second.
And it turns out to be easy
to maintain in log n time.
So let's prove some stuff.
So first claim is that
AVL trees are balanced.
Balanced, remember, means
that the height of them
is always order log n.
So we're just going to assume
for now that we can somehow
achieve this property.
We want to prove that it
implies that the height is
at most some
constant times log n.
We know it's at
least log n, but also
like it to be not much bigger.
So what do you think
is the worst case?
Say I have n nodes.
How could I make the
tree as high as possible?
Or conversely, if I have
a particular height,
how could I make it have
as few nodes as possible?
That'd be like the
sparsest, the least balanced
situation for AVL trees.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could have
one node on the last level.
PROFESSOR: One node on the last
level, yeah, in particular.
Little more.
What do the other
levels look like?
That is correct, but I want
to know the whole tree.
It's hard to explain
the tree, but you
can explain the core
property of the tree.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: For every
node, let's make
the right side have a height of
one larger than the left side.
I think that's worth a cushion.
See if I can throw better.
Good catch.
Better than hitting your eye.
So I'm going to not
prove this formally,
but I think if you stare
at this long enough it's
pretty obvious.
Worst case is when-- there
are multiple worst cases,
because right and
left are symmetric.
We don't really care.
But let's say that
the right subtree
has height one more than
the left for every node.
OK, this is a little
tricky to draw.
Not even sure I want
to try to draw it.
But you basically
draw it recursively.
So, OK, somehow I've
figured out this
where the height
difference here is 1.
Then I take two copies of it.
It's like a fractal.
You should know all
about fractals by now.
Problem set two.
And then you just-- well,
that's not quite right.
In fact, I need to somehow
make this one a little
bit taller and then
glue these together.
Little tricky.
Let's not even try
to draw the tree.
Let's just imagine
this is possible.
It is possible.
And instead, I'm going
to use mathematics
to understand how
high that tree is.
Or actually, it's
a little easier
to think about-- let
me get this right.
It's so easy that I
have to look at my notes
to remember what to write.
Really, no problem.
All right, so I'm
going to define n sub h
is the minimum number
of nodes that's
possible in an AVL
tree of height h.
This is sort of the inverse
of what we care about,
but if we can solve the
inverse, we can solve the thing.
What we really care about
is, for n nodes, how large
can the height be?
We want to prove
that's order log n.
But it'll be a lot easier to
think about the reverse, which
is, if I fix the height to
be h, what's the fewest nodes
that I can pack in?
Because for the very unbalanced
tree, I have a height of n,
and I only need to put n nodes.
That would be really bad.
What I prefer is a situation
like this, where with height h,
I have to put in
2 to the h nodes.
That would be perfect balance.
Any constant to the h will do.
So when you take the
inverse, you get a log.
OK, we'll get to
that in a moment.
How should we analyze n sub h?
I hear something.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 2 to
the h minus 1 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Maybe, but I don't
think that will quite work out.
Any-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you have only
1 node in the last level,
so it would be 1/2
to the h plus 1.
PROFESSOR: That turns out
to be approximately correct,
but I don't know where you
got 1/2 to the h plus 1.
It's not exactly correct.
I'll tell you that, so that
your analysis isn't right.
It's a lot easier.
You guys are worried
about the last level
and actually what the tree looks
like, but in fact, all you need
is this.
All you need is love, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, it's not a half.
It's a different constant.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Start with base cases
and write a recursive formula.
PROFESSOR: Ah,
recursive formula.
Good.
You said start with base cases.
I always forget that part, so
it's good that you remember.
You should start
with the base case,
but I'm not going to
worry about the base case
because it won't matter.
Because I know the base case
is always going to be n order 1
is order 1.
So for algorithms,
that's usually all
you need for base case, but it's
good that you think about it.
What I was looking for
is recursive formula,
aka, recurrence.
So can someone tell me--
maybe even you-- could tell me
a recurrence for n sub h,
in terms of n sub smaller h?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 1 plus [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 1 plus
n sub h minus 1.
Not quite.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: N sub h minus
1 plus n sub h minus 2.
PROFESSOR: N plus-- do
you want the 1 plus?
AUDIENCE: I don't think so.
PROFESSOR: You do.
It's a collaboration.
To combine your
two answers, this
should be the correct formula.
Let me double check.
Yes, whew.
Good.
OK, why?
Because the one thing we know is
that our tree looks like this.
The total height here is h.
That's what we're
trying to figure out.
How many nodes are in
this tree of height h?
Well, the height is the
max of the two directions.
So that means that the
larger has height h minus 1,
because the longest
path to a leaf
is going to be down this way.
What's the height of this?
Well, it's one less
than the height of this.
So it's going to be h minus 2.
This is where the n sub h minus
1 plus n sub h minus 2 come in.
But there's also this node.
It doesn't actually make a big
difference in this recurrence.
This is the exponential part.
This is like itty bitty thing.
But it matters for the
base case is pretty much
where it matters.
Back to your base case.
There's one guy here, plus
all the nodes on the left,
plus all the nodes on the right.
And for whatever
reason, I put the left
over here and the
right over here.
And of course, you could
reverse this picture.
It doesn't really matter.
You get the same formula.
That's the point.
So this is the recurrence.
Now we need to solve it.
What we would like is
for it to be exponential,
because that means there's a
lot of nodes in a height h AVL
tree.
So any suggestions on
how we could figure out
this recurrence?
Does it look like anything
you've seen before?
AUDIENCE: Fibonacci.
PROFESSOR: Fibonacci.
It's almost Fibonacci.
If I hid this plus 1,
which you wanted to do,
then it would be
exactly Fibonacci.
Well, that's actually good,
because in particular, n sub h
is bigger than Fibonacci.
If you add one at
every single level,
the certainly you
get something bigger
than the base
Fibonacci sequence.
Now, hopefully you know
Fibonacci is exponential.
I have an exact formula.
If you take the golden ratio to
the power h, divide by root 5,
and round to the
nearest integer,
you get exactly the
Fibonacci number.
Crazy stuff.
We don't need to
know why that's true.
Just take it as fact.
And conveniently phi
is bigger than 1.
You don't need to
remember what phi
is, except it is bigger than 1.
And so this is an
exponential bound.
This is good news.
So I'll tell you
it's about 1.618.
And so we get is that--
if we invert this,
this says n sub h is bigger
than some phi to the h.
This is our n, basically.
What we really
want to know is how
h relates to n, which is
just inverting this formula.
So we have, on the
other hand, the phi
to the h divided by
root 5 is less than n.
So I got a log base
phi on both sides.
Seems like a good thing to do.
This is actually quite annoying.
I've got h minus a
tiny little thing.
It's less than
log base phi of n.
And I will tell you that is
about 1.440 times log base 2
of n, because after all,
log base 2 is what computer
scientists care about.
So just to put it
into perspective.
We want it to be
theta log base 2 of n.
And here's the bound.
The height is always less
than 1.44 times log n.
All we care about
is some constant,
but this is a pretty
good constant.
We'd like one.
There are binary search tress
that achieve 1, plus very,
very tiny thing, arbitrarily
tiny, but this is pretty good.
Now, if you don't know
Fibonacci numbers,
I pull a rabbit out of a hat
and I've got this phi to the h.
It's kind of magical.
There's a much easier way
to analyze this recurrence.
I'll just tell you because
it's good to know but not
super critical.
So we have this
recurrence, n sub h.
This is the computer scientist
way to solve the recurrence.
We don't care about
the constants.
This is the theoretical
computer scientist
way to solve this recurrence.
We don't care about constants.
And so we say, aw, this is hard.
I've got n sub h minus
1 and n sub h minus 2.
So asymmetric.
Let's symmetrify.
Could I make them
both n sub h minus 1.
Or could I make them
both n sub h minus 2?
Suggestions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Minus
2 is the right way
to go because I want to know n
sub h is greater than something
in order to get a
less than down here.
By the way, I use that
log is monatomic here,
but it is, so we're good.
So this is going to
be greater than 1
plus 2 times n sub h minus 2.
Because if I have
a larger height
I'm going to have more nodes.
That's an easy
proof by induction.
So I can combine
these into one term.
It's simpler.
I can get rid of this 1 because
that only makes things bigger.
So I just have this.
OK, now I need a
base case, but this
looks like 2 the something.
What's the something?
H over 2.
So I'll just write theta
to avoid the base case.
2 to the h over 2.
Every two steps of h, I
get another factor of 2.
So when you invert
and do the log,
this means that h is also
less than log base 2 of n.
Log base 2 because of that.
Factor 2 out here
because of that factor 2
when you take the log.
And so the real answer is 1.44.
This is the correct--
this is the worst case.
But it's really easy to prove
that it's, at most, 2 log n.
So keep this in
mind in case we ask
you to analyze
variance of AVL trees,
like in problem set three.
This is the easy way
to do it and just get
some constant times log n.
Clear?
All right, so that's AVL
trees, why they're balanced.
And so if we can
achieve this property,
that the left and right subtrees
have about the same height,
we'll be done.
So how the heck do we
maintain that property?
Let's go over here.
Mobius trees are
supposed to support
a whole bunch of operations,
but in particular, insert
and delete.
I'm just going to worry
about insert today.
Delete is almost identical.
And it's in the code that
corresponds to this lecture,
so you can take a look at it.
Very, very similar.
Let's start with insert.
Well, it's pretty
straightforward.
Our algorithm is as follows.
We do the simple BST insertion,
which we already saw,
which is you walk down the tree
to find where that key fits.
You search for that key.
And wherever it isn't,
you insert a node there,
insert a new leaf,
and add it in.
Now, this will not
preserve the AVL property.
So the second step is
fix the AVL property.
And there's a nice concise
description of AVL insertion.
Of course, how do you do step
two is the interesting part.
All right, maybe let's
start with an example.
That could be fun.
Hey, look, here's an example.
And to match the
notes, I'm going
to do insert 23 as
a first example.
OK, I'm also going to annotate
this tree a little bit.
So I said we store
the heights, but what
I care about is which height is
larger, the left or the right.
In fact, you could
just store that,
just store whether
it's plus 1, minus 1,
or 0, the difference between
left and right sides.
So I'm going to draw that
with a little icon, which
is a left arrow, a
descending left arrow if this
is the bigger side.
And this is a right arrow.
This is even.
Left and right are the same.
Here, the left is heavier,
or higher, I guess.
Here it's even.
Here it's left.
This is AVL, because
it's only one
heavier wherever
I have an arrow.
OK, now I insert 23.
23 belongs-- it's less than 41,
greater than 20, less than 29,
less than 26.
So it belongs here.
Here's 23, a brand-new node.
OK, now all the heights change.
And it's annoying to draw
what the heights are,
but I'll do it.
This one changes to 1.
This is 0.
This changes to 2.
This changes to 3.
This changes to 4.
Anyway, never mind
what the heights are.
What's bad is, well,
this guy's even.
This guy's left heavy.
This guy's now
doubly left heavy.
Bad news.
OK, let's not worry
about above that.
Let's just start.
The algorithm is going
to walk up the tree
and say, oh, when do
I get something bad?
So now I have 23,
26, 29 in a path.
I'd like to fix it.
Hmm, how to fix it?
I don't think we know how to
fix it, so I will tell you how.
Actually, I wasn't
here last week.
So did we cover rotations?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
Then you don't know.
Let me tell you about rotations.
Super cool.
It's just a tool.
That's x and y.
I always get these mixed up.
So this is called
left rotate of x.
OK, so here's the thing we can
do with binary search trees.
It's like the only
thing you need to know.
Because you've got search
in binary search trees
and you've got rotations.
So when I have a tree like this,
I've highlighted two nodes,
and then there's the
children hanging off of them.
Some of these might be
empty, but they're trees,
so we draw them as triangles.
If I just do this,
which is like changing
which is higher, x or y, and
whatever the parent of x was
becomes the parent of y.
And vice versa, in fact.
The parent of y was x, and
now the parent of x is y.
OK, the parent of a is still x.
The parent of b changes.
It used to be y.
Now it's x.
The parent of c was y.
It's still y.
So in a constant number
of pointer changes,
I can go from this to this.
This is constant time.
And more importantly, it
satisfies the BST order
property.
If you do an in-order
traversal of this,
you will get a, x, b, y, c.
If I do an in-order traversal
over here, I get a, x, b, y, c.
So they're the same.
So it still has BST ordering.
You can check more formally.
b has all the nodes
between x and y.
Still all the nodes
between x and y, and so on.
You can check it at
home, but this works.
We call it a left rotate because
the root moves to the left.
You can go straight back
where you came from.
This would be a
right rotate of y.
OK, it's a reversible operation.
It lets you manipulate the tree.
So when we have this
picture and we're
really sad because this
looks like a mess, what
we'd like to do is fix it.
This is a path of three nodes.
We'd really prefer
it to look like this.
If we could make that
transformation, we'd be happy.
And we can.
It is a right rotate of 29.
So that's what
we're going to do.
So let me quickly copy.
I want to rotate 29
to the right, which
means 29 and 26-- this is x.
This is y.
I turn them, and so
I get 26 here now,
and 29 is the new right child.
And then whatever
was the left child
of x becomes the left
child of x in the picture.
You can check it.
So this used to
be the triangle a.
And in this case,
it's just the node 23.
And we are happy.
Except I didn't
draw the whole tree.
Now we're happy because
we have an AVL tree again.
Good news.
So just check.
This is even.
This is right heavy.
This is left heavy still.
This is left heavy,
even, even, even.
OK, so now we have an AVL tree
and our beauty is restored.
I'll do one more example.
Insert 55.
We want to insert 55 here.
And what changes is
now this is even.
This is right heavy.
This is doubly left heavy.
We're super sad.
And then we don't look
above that until later.
This is more
annoying, because you
look at this thing,
this little path.
It's a zigzag path, if you will.
If I do a right rotation
where this is x and this
is y, what I'll get is
x, y, and then this is b.
This is what's in
between x and y.
And so it'll go here.
And now it's a zag zig
path, which is no better.
The height's the same.
And we're sad.
I told you, though,
that somehow rotations
are all we need to do.
What can I do?
How could I fix
this little zigzag?
Just need to think
about those three nodes,
but all I give
you are rotations.
AUDIENCE: Perhaps rotate 50.
PROFESSOR: Maybe rotate 50.
That seems like a good idea.
Let's try it.
If you don't mind, I'm
just going to write 41,
and then there's all
the stuff on the left.
Now we rotate 50.
So 65 remains where it is.
And we rotate 50 to the left.
So 50 and its child.
This is x.
This is y.
And so I get 55 and I get 50.
Now, this is bad from
an AVL perspective.
This is still doubly left
heavy, this is left heavy,
and this is even.
But it looks like this case.
And so now I can do a
right rotation on 65,
and I will get-- so let me
order the diagrams here.
I do a right rotate on
65, and I will get 41.
And to the right I get 55.
And to the right I get 65.
To the left I get 50.
And then I get the left subtree.
And so now this is
even, even, even.
Wow.
How high was left subtree?
I think it's still left heavy.
Cool.
This is what some people
call double rotation,
but I like to call
it two rotations.
It's whatever you prefer.
It's not really a new operation.
It's just doing two rotations.
So that's an example.
Let's do the general case.
It's no harder.
You might say, oh, gosh,
why do you do two examples?
Well, because they
were different.
And they're are two
cases on the algorithm.
You need to know both of them.
OK, so AVL insert.
Here we go.
Fix AVL property.
I'm just going to call this
from the changed node up.
So the one thing that's
missing from these examples
is that you might have to
do more than two rotations.
What we did was look at the
lowest violation of the AVL
property and we fixed it.
When we do that,
there's still may
be violations higher up,
because when you add a node,
you change the height
of this subtree,
the height of this subtree,
and the height of this
subtree, potentially.
What happened in these
cases when I was done,
what I did fixed one violation.
They were all fixed.
But in general, there might be
several violations up the tree.
So that's what we do.
Yeah, I'll leave it at that.
So suppose x is the lowest
node that is not AVL.
The way we find that node
is we start at the node
that we changed.
We check if that's OK.
We update the heights as we
go up using our simple rule.
And that's actually not our
simple rule, but it's erased.
We update the height based on
the heights of its children.
And you keep
walking up until you
see, oh, the left is twice,
two times-- or not two times,
but plus 2 larger than
the left, or vice versa.
Then you say, oh, that's bad.
And so we fix it.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: So here we
continue to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
add n to the level
[INAUDIBLE] than 1.
So add [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: AVL property's
not about levels.
It's about left subtrees
and right subtrees.
So the trouble is that 65--
you have a left subtree, which
has height 2-- or sorry,
height 1, I guess--
because the longest path
from here to a leaf is 1.
The right subtree
has height negative 1
because it doesn't exist.
So it's one versus negative 1.
So that's why there's
a double arrow.
Yeah, good to ask.
It's weird with the negative 1s.
That's also why I wanted to
define those negative 1s to be
there, so the AVL property
is easier to state.
Other questions?
All right.
Good.
I think I want a
symmetry assumption here.
I don't know why I
wrote right of x.
I guess in modern days
we write x dot right.
Same thing.
OK, I'm going to assume that
the right child is the heavier
one like we did before.
Could be the left.
It's symmetric.
It doesn't matter.
So now there are two
cases, like I said.
I'm going to use
this term right heavy
because it's super convenient.
OK, right heavy
is what I've been
drawing by a
descending right arrow.
Balance is what I've been
drawing by a horizontal line.
OK, so we're just distinguishing
between these two cases.
This turns out to
be the easy case.
So we have x, y, a, b, c.
Why are we looking
at the right child?
Because we assumed that the
right one is higher, so that x
was right heavy.
So this subtree as I've drawn
it is higher than the left one
by 2, in fact.
And what we do in this
case is right rotate of x.
And so we get x, y, a, b, c.
I could have drawn this no
matter what case we're in,
so we need to check
this actually works.
That's the interesting part.
And that's over here.
OK, so I said x is right
heavy, in fact doubly so.
y is either right
heavy or balanced.
Let's start with right heavy.
So when we do this rotation,
what happens to the heights?
Well, it's hard to tell.
It's a lot easier to think about
what the actual heights are
than just these arrows.
So let's suppose x has height k.
That's pretty generic.
And it's right
heavy, so that means
the y has height k minus 1.
And then this is right heavy,
so this has height k minus 2.
And this is something
smaller then k minus 2.
In fact, because this
is AVL, we assume
that x was the lowest
that is not AVL.
So y is AVL.
And so this is going
to be k minus 3,
and this is going to be k minus
3 because these differ by 2.
You can prove by a simple
induction you never
get more than 2 out of whack
because we're just adding 1,
off by 1.
So we got off by 2.
So this is the bad situation.
Now we can just update
the heights over here.
So k minus 3 for a, k minus
3 for b, k minus 2 for c.
Those don't change because
we didn't touch those trees,
and height is about
going down, not up.
And so this becomes k minus
2, and this becomes k minus 1.
And so we changed the
height of the root,
but now you can see
that life is good.
This is now balanced between
k minus 3 and k minus 3.
k minus 2 and k minus 2.
And now the parent of
y may be messed up,
and that's why after this
we go to the parent of y,
see if it's messed up, but
keep working our way up.
But it worked.
And in the interest
of time, I will not
check the case
where y is balanced,
but it works out, too.
And see the notes.
So the other case is
where we do two rotations.
And in general, so here
x was doubly right heavy.
And the else case is
when the right child
of x, which I'm going to
call z here, is left heavy.
That's the one
remaining situation.
You do the same
thing, and you check
that right rotating and
left rotating, which
makes the nice picture,
which is x, y, z,
actually balances everything and
you restore the AVL property.
So again, check
the notes on that.
I have a couple minutes
left, and instead I'd
like to tell you a
little bit about how
this fits into big-picture land.
Two things I want to talk about.
One is you could
use this, of course,
to sort, which is, if you
want to sort n numbers,
you insert them and you
do in-order traversal.
How long does this take?
In-order traversal
takes linear time.
That's the sense in which we're
storing things in sorted order.
Inserting n items-- well,
each insert takes h time,
but now we're guaranteed
that h is order log n.
So all the insertions take log
n time each, n log n total.
So this is yet another way to
sort n items in n log n time,
in some ways the
most powerful way.
We've seen heaps, and
we've seen merge sort.
They all sort.
Heaps let you do two operations,
insert and delete min, which
a lot of times is all you
care about, like in p set two.
But these guys,
AVL trees, let you
do insert, delete,
and delete min.
So they're the same
in those senses,
but we have the new
operation, which
is that we can do find next
larger and next smaller, aka
successor and predecessor.
So you can think about what
we call an abstract data type.
These are the operations
that you support,
or that you're
supposed to support.
If you're into Java, you
call this an interface.
But this is an
algorithmic specification
of what your data structure
is supposed to do.
So we have operations
like insert and delete.
We have operations
like find the min
and things like successor
and predecessor,
or next larger, next smaller.
You can take any subset of these
and it's an abstract data type.
Insert, delete, and min is
called a priority queue.
So if you just take
these first two,
it's called a priority queue.
And there are many
priority queues.
This is a generic thing
that you might want to do.
And then the data
structure on the other side
is how you actually do it.
This is the analog
of the algorithm.
OK, this is the specification.
You want a priority queue.
One way to do it is a heap.
Another way to do
it is an AVL tree.
You could do it
with a sorted array.
You could do lots of
sub-optimal things, too,
but in particular, heaps
get these two operations.
If you want all
three, you basically
need a balanced
binary search tree.
There are probably a dozen
balanced binary search trees
out there, at least a dozen
balanced search trees,
not all binary.
They all achieve log n.
So it doesn't really matter.
There are various practical
issues, constant factors,
things like that.
The main reason you prefer a
heap is that it's in place.
It doesn't use any extra space.
Here, you've got pointers
all over the place.
You lose a constant
factor in space.
But from a theoretical
standpoint,
if you don't care
about constant factors,
AVL trees are really good
because they get everything
that we've seen
so far and log n.
And I'll stop there.